quant à la fréquence des visites de
monsieur benalla la préfecture de police
je n'ai souvenir à titre personnel que
deux je réfléchis mais que de deux ou
trois de ses visites
la première visite je voulais 10 dont
j'ai souvenir c'était dans le cadre de
la préparation de la soirée du second
tour de l'élection présidentielle donc
début mai 5 ou 4 ou 5 mai de 2010 est là
les suivantes parce qu'il y en a eu
plusieurs
c'était dans le cadre de la préparation
du one planet subite qui s'est passé à
boulogne billancourt le nouvel ensemble
boulogne billancourt vous nous allons
travailler avec les services de la
présidence de république et monsieur
benalla était présent ce sont les deux
seules visites que j'ai à ma
connaissance et dont je ne traîne pas
être frustré de la réponse donc ce sont
les services des préfectures de police
qui ont imaginé os conçu comme monsieur
bennett est chargé de mission de
coordination de la sécurité parce que
dans la note de service décrivant son
activité c'était que l'organisation des
déplacements publics et privés et
éventuellement les réceptions à la
présence d'un public je vais expliquer à
monsieur trou et pourquoi il posant ces
questions parce qu'il est possible
il a beaucoup de travail qui dit pas
assisté à toutes nos éditions
bien qu'elle soit publique mais sachez
monsieur drouet que la définition
formelle qui nous a été donné dès
fonctions de monsieur benalla lors de
nos premières auditions à la fin du mois
de juillet en début du mois d'août
comportait exclusivement droit points la
participation à l'organisation des
déplacements publics du président de la
république
l'organisation
2d de l'accueil des visiteurs pour le 14
juillet car car ils sont très nombreux
et le troisième point c'était
l'organisation n'ont pas seulement la
participation mais l'organisation des
déplacements privés du chef de l'état ou
de son épouse et ça n'est que et sané
oui c'est cela c'était sa responsabilité
en propre voilà les explications que
nous a donnée sur sa fonction
puis plus récemment on nous a dit c'est
de la semaine dernière le chef de
cabinet du président de la république
il avait aussi une fonction de
coordination du gspr et du commandement
militaire du palais je crois que dans
l'esprit de la description de cette
fonction de coordination ça ne veut pas
dire que le coordinateur comme peut
l'être le coordinateur du renseignement
national se situe au sommet de la
pyramide mais que dans la pratique du
fonctionnement quotidien
il avait à jouer un rôle de trait
d'union et voilà que cette semaine est
on nous explique que alors il pensait
que sa facilité la justification du port
d'armes qu'ils exercent une mission de
sécurité mais cette semaine fait nouveau
monsieur benalla lui même vous aussi
vous nous indiquez que non ça n'était
pas pour une fonction de sécurité
c'était pour sa protection personnelle
on se demande qu'est ce qui spécifie
qu'on pouvait bien exposé à ce poids
monsieur benalla à des risques puisque
il avait une fonction que l'on nous a
décrite comme une fonction
d'organisation et même la coordination
comme une fonction que dont il ne faut
pas exagérer l'importance hiérarchique
qui ne plaçait pas au dessus de dés des
chefs du j'espère ou du commandant
commandant militaire du palais voilà
pourquoi monsieur grosdidier à 6 pour
essayer de comprendre parce que
finalement il y a eu des versions
évolutives du du de la mission exacte de
monsieur benalla et dans toutes ses
versions reste une énigme
mais pourquoi donc avait-il besoin d'une
arme il nous a dit lui même qu'il
pouvait avoir sur lui cette arme en
présence du chef de l'état soit dans des
déplacements privés 60 soit dans des
placements publics qu'il le pouvait
l'amener à l'elysée vous n'avez pas à
nous répondre sur ce que faisait
exactement monsieur bennama puisque vous
n'êtes pas censé le savoir en revanche
la préfecture de police étaient censés
avoir des éléments objectifs suffisant
pour pouvoir affirmer dans l'arrêté
autorisant le port d'armes que monsieur
benalla exercer une fonction de police
ces voix là alors je vous laisse
répondre à la question monsieur
grosdidier
après avoir essayé de vous donner deux
contextes cette question parce que
nous n'avons pas encore à ce jour réussi
à avoir une vision parfaitement clair de
et de 7,2 cette fonction alors allez-y
monsieur drouet si vous pouvez monter un
petit complément d'information il sera
le bienvenu
m monsieur par nos messieurs de rappeler
m'en voyez vous monsieur yann drouet
nous entendons beaucoup de personnes qui
nous exposent des choses et au bout d'un
moment j'ai envie de vous demander quel
est votre sentiment intime profond votre
conviction
on a peut-être à tort le sentiment qu'on
nous expose de beaucoup de manières d
minimisation du rôle de monsieur benalla
mais qu'en réalité il était l'homme de
confiance qui à cet égard disposer d'un
pouvoir très large jusqu'à être
finalement peut-être j'emploie cet
adverbe riez vous le maître d'oeuvre
d'une réorganisation de la sécurité du
chef de l'état dans toutes ses
dimensions
quand bien même ce serait en opposition
avec le ministère de l'intérieur
et vous vous avez comme nous lu cette
phrase entre guillemets dans le journal
du dimanche je pense que le dimanche
colisée le journal du dimanche
oh il fait état lui même de l'opposition
du ministère de l'intérieur pas si vous
voyez le l'adjoint au chef de cabinet du
chef de l'état qui dit ben voilà le
ministère de l'intérieur est opposé à
mes visions et en tant que fonctionnaire
de la république qu'est ce que vous
pensez tout ça alors monsieur dray
c'est en j'ai été convoqué en tant
qu'ancien chef de cabinet du préfet de
police et donc c'est que en tant
police donc fonctionnaires que je vais
vous répondre
monsieur le sénateur je voudrais réagir
à ce que dit monsieur grosdidier est ce
que vous avez dit dans l'arrêté la
mention portant à l'action de
coordination des services de sécurité de
la présidence de la république en lien
avec le gspr une force de sécurité
c'est donc dans le dossier qui nous
avait été fourni que nous avons trouvé
cette mention et c'est de cette mention
que nous avons estimé
nous avons jugé que ça pouvait être
assimilée à une mission de police
mais il ne faut pas isoler les choses
c'est ce que je vous ai dit tout à
l'heure dans la façon nous avons examiné
le dossier c'est un ensemble et donc on
a considéré son action de coordination
des services de sécurité de la
présidence
on a estimé qu'il exerçait sa mission
auprès du président de la république une
des personnalités les plus menacées
france dans un contexte de menaces
terroristes des plus élevés et on a
considéré que dans le cadre de ses
fonctions dans le cadre de sa mission
il était manifestement exposés à des
risques c'est l'ensemble qu'on a
considéré c'est l'ensemble qu'on a
considéré monsieur prison